I think if people have no. Nothing more in common than wanting to live in the country.
And they don't even from the start. What you know i think. These are the people i want to live with.
But just that they all come together for economic reasons that. It's quite stunning if they succeed.
And can overcome the conflict and find the motivation. To solve problems with doubts. I think we were at it.
Made it really easy for us else to have a set of spiritually based. You know century that we had in common.
I think that was really important. Well if you know mike lee.
We're not self-sustaining in any sense and in fact where i'm from the beginning we never.
Made any claims that that's what we wanted to do or anything so we haven't had that sort of ideal to live up to.
Economically i don't think communities are viable. The whole society. Works against it and.
Some people in fact mourn the fact that here the days are gone
when everybody was home every day doing things on the phone. Because we're not anymore.
Just about everybody's got a job. People are studying. Some days. There would only be a couple of people at home and.
You know you could easily say oh isn't that sad they're not together anymore. But again.
You know your needs and your interests change and.
Most of us are at the time in our lives when we really want to be mixing it up in the wider community. So.
I don't know if this place is viable but it shouldn't be by any sort of. Standards you know i just it just.
I think works in spite of. In spite of the forces around it some. Yes absolutely absolutely.
There's some people here who never would be on the job. But most of us were.
And of course at that time it was very easy to be. A couple years after we were here.
We were quite effected by a man named stephen gaskin who was there later as if i'm in tennessee
and came to the main area and talked with lots of people around and. We at that time body found discussed how could we.
Number one and. Share our income totally did we want to do that in could we create our own livelihood.
So that we could get off the dole some of us did.
My partner and i started a business which supported us for five years and. Also employed other people on the phone.
But we were never that tight a group that we could all agree or people were willing to put aside their own interests
and say oh yes ok. Well here's an income generating. Thing i'm going to forget about what i want to do and do this.
That just never worked. And yes so the welfare state of course. In many ways made this possible. Sure.
Yeah yeah yeah well terrain creek was a tremendous thing for us. Lots of other people.
My partner at the time john seed chris is now. A globe trotter for the rain forest.
And there's lots of other people who have very strong. Leanings in that way this.
To people who live here now who work very hard for the rain forest informations. And we've supported lots of projects.
To do with fighting and sand mining and. Deforestation all kinds of things like that.
So of course it's a very very strong. Value that we hold. And sometimes.
Sometimes i think about the wider community in general like you know. Name and. Be everywhere that.
Maybe we're just pawns in the trees hands and all that.
All that really matters about what about coming here
and living in this area is that in some way that the trees are got a chance to grow. Well they're in a position.
That's a fantasy that if we do nothing else. That's fantastic. Yeah. Yeah.
Just about the whole time ended up down at the creek camp and. We'd already had a bit of. You know.
Practice in organizing ourselves in let's do some people got involved in running the first a sort of organisation down
there and others were into communication. And that. That interest rate. Stayed very strong.
Several people went down to the franklin and also to gun responsible jobs in helping that. Movement.
Do the job it had to do. And then years later. Course there was the fight for the night camp national forest.
And again i mean like there was a big bamboo aerial. Pole off my bread and a c.b.
Radio going all the time from the mountain. This is a black stump over to silence. And. And.
It's always been a really good feeling for people here to get involved you know to lend a hand
and become involved in those things and. John seed left here about nine years ago. Left like the five. But we really.
Support what he does and. Welcome him back when every comes back to us trail and. He gets a lot of support.
Moral support from the people here. Yeah. Well green and also other things too. I mean there's a couple of people. Ok.
I guess that we see. Spiritual inquiry. As all. All those things as having to do with greenness and.
With multiculturalism and so on i mean it's not the first time that a sporting is environmental is and.
Is to us i think also the question of native native peoples. Is important to us. Education on all levels.
We see as part of that people are involved in primary. And tertiary education here.
And things like we have to we have two guys here who are very very much into men. The men's issues and.
Really like organizing groups of men to talk about where their place in the scheme of things in it is so. Yes.
I do yeah about what's so worthwhile spiritual pursuit. Is very very broad. I mean they. This.
Also presume here who's actually leading retreats now. And self so.
Is the whole gamut of other people who feel that a very good way of inquiry serco counseling
and run code counseling groups.
Which is a very egalitarian type way of working through one's issues which doesn't involve paying someone a lot of
money and. We keep planting trees which is where that question stat it is really important but.
Just it when your kids grow up and. I guess we just see it is it getting brought you know.
What's important is broader and broader all the time. Speaking oh. Well it's an absolutely wonderful place.
I don't i often wonder what the kids will say.
You know when someone asked them when they're twenty five or thirty how they felt about it. But it's a safe place.
We've got twenty kids around twenty kids in the place. From fifteen years down to four months and.
A lot of those kids have grown up together. Which i think. Is a wonderful thing and was really important.
Will be important in their lives. I've always been quite amazed that. Most of our kids. Don't go. Bush.
They actually don't go exploring in the bush much. I don't know why. But they sure have a good time together here.
I bloody well. Thank you anderson. Anderson yes i mean he is i mean and stewart spit with a city. You know i think.
My name stuart anderson.
And i lived on friday for fifteen years ever since it began a father of four children and sole parent now with.
What's a part time sole parent with three boys come and go with them to weekly combat and my daughter lives in town.
And with the boys who are alone here a body found. Tweens born here at fourteen years ago.
And then the next going to obviously a long time. I'm very much proud of this place.
And you know i feel a lot of affinity for the land and the people here and i know that on. Whale. Well loved and.
I feel needed and part of the prize and that's a wonderful feeling. I've done a range of things in my life.
When i first came here i was a part of. And i set up a pottery. Here.
Which was pretty difficult because we had twins at the same time. And in those days. I had both.
Messages running inside of me but to not be on the dollar and get myself established. And be the provider out.
And also to be the new age dad and do at least fifty percent of the childcare.
Which meant that i just was running it was crazy and new age.
That we considered ourselves out on the communication was very good in this. In that marriage and.
And say seven years later we split up when it was. It was pretty had.
We were daisy and i say that i think i saw enough time to really enjoy each other's company and so on.
When i got from there. There were quite a few things that attracted me to buddy.
And the spiritual or the inquiry into life sort of side of it was a strong one. I had been investigating various.
So-called spiritual avenues the anonymous. And so on and i hadn't. Being particularly drawn to any of them.
Transcendental meditation or whatever.
When i came up here and met the people and and talked to them about their approach with meditation and. Inquiry.
I was really impressed he was a know. Non-dogmatic straight forward sort of.
Practical way of sort of gaining wisdom becoming. Getting to know oneself and getting to know all of life and so on.
And of course there was lots of in the eyes days. We were. Most people have been to india.
And said there were a lot of. Wherein of just sort of indian type clothes for the women and one for the main.
And using indian phrases and sour and.
All sorts of when you say tricky things and enlightenment and girls and things like that which.
I could take although you had been to india but not.
Not on a spiritual quest i mean more and more as a traveler and just enjoying seeing the place and
and olie all the different travelers i mean it.
So that's one thing that attracted me was the non-dogmatic fairly practical. Inquiry. And the time.
Put aside for that and. And that was attractive not only just for myself but also really.
That had good implications for the community it meant that. Any conflict. Or controversy whatever that arise. Was.
Looked at in the light of all what can we learn from these two people having differing opinions
or really feeling angry with each other also behind them in within the community was expected. Of s.o.'s and of.
Each other that we did. We would. Ask yes it will have a contributing to this conflict or whatever it is.
So i was a priest for the mill. Things to learn more from. So that was attractive.
What else was attractive about all this bush this land. It was originally i don't know if you've been told.
Chosen because it had a lovely swimming hole that's about have practical way that.
Running around looking for land ah there's a lovely swimming pool swimming hole in this bit of land and by that.
You know and so agriculturally it's ridiculous and. I think one of the main advantages is that.
That it's not directly on a on a mine ride or anything like that and so it's very very quiet and peaceful here.
And people have to make a bit of an effort to come in they mean it's not right on the y. and. And.
Well there were only half an hour from town it just seems like. It's not easy just a drop in. Personally i wasn't.
I've been living on the it down in the little town called to wamba.
Which is just in one of aden in fast south coast of new south wales. And i've really enjoyed the. Village life there.
Knowing a lot of coals and the history that went right back and feeling excepted in feeling like i could contribute.
And that i got my ensoul and one thing i regret.
Regretted about meeting up to this community is i didn't get to make the local so much because we were so busy building
at houses and getting to know each other and and swimming in a lovely so. Sell it and maybe.
You know young dieties everyway at it. I didn't get a chance to meet the locals and i've always felt that.
Out of the gap and. Seems inevitable in a way in and out of that gap there's been a lot of misconceptions about biting.
Where a batter. For example way before last. Me every year we go on and then. We spend a week together.
Having what we call their annual general meeting. It's a company.
Because with my company owns the land for us we have to have this meeting legally
but we use it as an excuse to spend time with one another talking about more long term things
and just enjoy each other's company and. Play and have fun. And we went to a camping ground called what do you hate.
And one of us i've heard. So some of the campus site. On campus i too another good.
Body but i haven't seen anyone in bribes. You know. And it's just that you know. Incredible for us.
And in the early days there was also the resistance from.
It's come to be known innes as the old settlers and there was room to spread about as deliberately and and.
You know that we sell by abuse that women who came and.
Really that we sold by a piece and there was a price i can't remember much ten thousand
or twenty thousand dollars was already q.o.s. and That no woman could come here.
And leave unless she was pregnant for some reason we've never quite figured that one out
but their own room is designed to put a stand and. Make us less acceptable. Not acceptable.
And that was just a small percentage i think of the michael. Because. Because having tweens was hard we didn't.
We hadn't built a house yet. We were in a lodge taint on the floor. We had a home or water but we didn't.
It was a crazy way to buy a nice.
And some of the locals who were very conservative were really very very supportive that is coming
when it have been running for months or whatever.
We could go and wash and that piece there and dry them and then just help us out in winter.
They could we stayed in a has a cup of tea while the washing was being done and and.
They were terrific and it wasn't until the. Attorney craig dispute which sort of split the community.
That seven hundred ten calls a night we just couldn't relate in the same way and i felt really sad about that.
And i imagine i did too but at the time i just was so upset and.
Somehow in my upset i accepted that i had to cut off from me like that. When we were in reasons for coming here.
Reasons for. Joining this community. I'd often indeed. I was brought up in camberwell in my high school yes.
And i often envied some. Couple of my younger brothers who'd gone to the school without walls where.
Camber which had a much freer an easier atmosphere.
And the students and the teachers were more intimate with one another that. They were very friendly got each other.
Hugs and seemed had a lot of fun together rather than just the normal straight jacket of school
and so are sort of jealous of that scene and i came here
and i just walked into a scene like that where people were very open and friendly and warm.
To me and invited me to converse with them at a deva level i suppose than normal and that really attracted me.
I feel that mediately that. I wanted to leave like that with a group of people like that.
I had investigated other communities before that and come across one quite like that. Me. Her and yeah.
We and i were very idealistic and i said i really idealistic.
We thought we would do everything for ourselves that we could. So that was build our own eyes as furniture.
Have our own booths or. Ceremonies director and rides. Are an income somehow it was.
You know no one wanted tavi on the place and. We had this. Sort of create i believe simply said.
Others can simply leave that. What is voluntary simplicity. And that.
So you know i've got no one to blame but myself you know why fit.
For what we went through but you know trying to build a house which wasn't a mud brick house of course. You know which.
You know i took took a lot of work and get a pottery together and raise young baby cries the way.
You know that she paid her for about sorry
but i thought it was just a lot more than turning on the tap in to find the wood
and lot the five it's a damp climates and everything in between would be way to delight and so on.
We might really hard for us and. But the early people it came on to this community where the pioneering time and.
Warrick and the other member of this community was only commenting to me i think it's more just that i morning that.
Thinking back on those days. He wasn't day and. Just thinking about what we did and he likened us to the early funny.
Show we had cast and some other. You know i had more resources at our disposal. But.
We really wanted to do it from the beginning in doing.
Do it for ourselves
and for the first couple of years it was sort of a friend upon to go out of the community just for your self you know
if you're going to go out then you should buy food for everyone else all the other people's needs
and so i going it was a major trick. I just meant if it would be out all day. And we just had. We had communal kind.
And i was. I know with another man with i was a mechanic. So. We worked on the communal couple while others.
Out of the rustic cooking rustic as we ate together every day. And so you know.
They were really sort of heady days to remain we. Working together a lot on buildings.
Feeling like we were all contributing to the same thing. Whatever.
That was we weren't quite you know couldn't quite benign
but it was building this community sharing our lives together as. Well mine broke out. But i can't claim just.
The communal. Setting. There's lots of affect this. And all of. I mean terms of. Partnership relationships.
And i think any civil. But that's not so unusual and. In it. And these times and. In this area or.
Mistry or whatever anyway. It was and.
It wasn't in terms the relationships of people in this community it wasn't apparent to me that it was a strain.
Well i think for some people who found it. And who weren't.
Building more into it because that's the way they feel they found it more difficult in and unfortunately.
Because i don't really know why but. Which suddenly had a whole lot of babies all at once who.
It meant that the sex role division just got said that women had babies who were breastfeeding and.
So to get them involved in the building was difficult especially because they had to be.
They just didn't seem inclined to pick it up in the same way that. The main expected of them so.
I mean this building we're sitting in the body from community center at the moment and.
I think about five or six years into our sins were established. I suggested to the community that we put aside.
Four months all of us try and sort of stop whatever work we were doing.
To work together on the community center because at the time we were in a shack that we call divine
and it was really beginning to get pretty ashamed of it.
It was very hard to keep clean and to function
and it just wasn't impressive to me any of the many ways it is that it came out why we attracted a lot of messages.
And that's another story in itself it was a multiple occupancy fight and so on
and my part of my dream in that that i did express but.
I don't think was taken on anyway i was that we'd work together on that we take each other building and.
There would be any quality. In how we'd build this building. And unfortunately i was away at the time.
Just for a month or so at the time that. Two or three others got into designing it.
And i designed this building which is beautiful to look at it six sided and.
Has it has a roof with a little put on top and light coming in and. And the kitchens. You know.
Spacious with lots of bench space and so on. Lots of wood. And it's high up with a good view.
But if you look at it it's not an easy building to build if you're nervous build it.
Every joint is an angle in it and you need an expert to tell you what to do which meant.
Which meant that the same old divisions of labor sprang up people feel disempowered.
The ones that didn't i had i really used tools and somewhat used to building filled this in pad
and there was this energy to just get this building built and. I just couldn't. No matter what i said.
I couldn't hold back. In fact. It. And literally happened that i said look. I'm not happy with this design.
And people said no we just want to get on with it more or less rushed out of the little shack
and started going for the system. I couldn't. And. And you know.
Them ones in their typical position of wanting something different but not wanting to put it down on everyone.
A damper on things. And people didn't understand what i was talking about it. Was that point coming from you. And yet.
You know it. You know with the idealism in the early days was a sort of a dog with him.
And a sort of a control of each other and their behavior and we had we had a lot of agreements. For instance.
And these were sort of like rooms. Although there was no sanctions. It was just. What you agreed to and things like.
We had no alcohol no diet. No dogs and cats.
And things that we still hold to social alcohol you know but we also had things like not driving on to the community
and nish absolutely had to.
So that it would be a caffre space all around the house which is lovely but which meant that some people ended up.
You know. Wheel bearing huge wide back and forth along the rides. To their place and.
You know really taking the brunt of a decision. And they were.
There was also unspoken agreements like for some reason in the early days no one had a radio and. We just sort of.
We were so inward looking. So we just want to. To get the same together.
We didn't really want to strike scenes from the outside world i think.
And we went finally one family one of the tavi there was a big divide. Which went on for.
Months until the people wanting the t.v. Got very frustrated and just got one anyway.
And that caused a fuel because some people very attractive.
Attached to the consensus process well you'll have to agree with or anything it was which is generally wonderful.
The consensus process i mean. Is just really like it. But it can lead to a dogmatism. And.
And i don't think that's healthy. I mean when people feel restricted by that sort of thing.
It'll come out sideways when some other way will come out in the future. And some unhealthy way.
Then when this tool is a little bit of.
Well i don't know i mean some people call it dogmatism other people would still call it common sense you know
vegetarianism. I mean that. One man. Not thinking clearly very clearly or something. Just bored.
Little several lawyers for how did the other day. And that upset really upset quite a few other members because they.
Because vegetarian. Is into them means he's part of a caring for life and. So.
Well that i would eating the meat i really feel like. None of us should. You know. On this community. That's.
That's what all the rules are you know like you know made on the community no diet and so on and.
On the community which means that you know technically you can go off and have your sausage in a joint. You know.
Cross the aisle water if you want to strike back in but it's. You know the rules of. Did they more. I see is more of a.
If i guard lines or.
To give someone especially from his coming to the place for the first time an idea of what i value for them
or a set of values. But we did have. We had five precepts as well which move buddhist in origin.
You know killing them and lying. You know taking what is not given. No six that hurts others. No intoxicants.
Or no things that confuse the mind. And i would more guard lines and. Misbehave a venue.
And they're still there and every one of them's been broken. You know.
Yet really really sure exactly exactly so i think there's a relaxed. Feel around. Rules and agreements these days.
And in growing lawrence and so on. You know they're not spoken of much.
They more or less just set the scene or something. And these days.
We i mean we do have a meditation hole in the property of it's very rarely used. Yet there's no.
Schedule or anything like that so it's just if someone wakes up in the morning and. Decides to go meditate.
Now go down there and bang on the gong outside and there's an invitation for any real food join them and one
or two others might total down. And that's it although we're still involved in running meditation retreats and.
Meditation is still very important in some people's lives here but not everyone. But inquiry.
Is still important i would say.
Doesn't have the same intensity that it did in the with that idea of inquiry being important doesn't have the same
intensity as it did. That's still there. And i really value that. Personally.